I can't sell culture comes for liberals
who decry the canceled culture Halle
Berry apologizes for acting and ill
ahead or makes clear once again
shouldn'ts move on to the United States
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show the venture Pierrot show is
sponsored by Express at DPN have a right
to privacy protected at expressvpn calm
slash Ben well Benjamin Franklin once
suggested that death and taxes were the
only inevitabilities wrong he was
canceled culture is an inevitability as
well everyone will be canceled unless
you're on the full-on woke left in which
case you can say anything I mean you can
you can literally quote hit learn if
you're on the full-on woke left you
won't be cancelled they'll be tried just
a little bit because you made everybody
look bad but you won't be cancelled for
that we'll get to that story in a little
while but cancel culture is quite real
it particularly exists not at the top
levels although it does exist at the top
levels I mean if you're the National
Book Critics Circle and half of your
board members are forced to resign or
not being sufficiently woke for not
being sufficiently suppli Kotori toward
a black lives matter the vulture calm
reported a week ago that twelve board
members of the National Book Critics
Circle an organization of eight hundred
critics began to draft a statement in
support of the black lives matter
movement noting the publishing industry
has long been overwhelmingly white from
top to bottom
they wrote of their culpability in this
system of a ratio of black and
indigenous voices from the cultural
conversation and listed a bunch of steps
they wanted to take his mail Mohammed
black writer and critic said it was
really exciting we were hoping to change
ourselves and then model something for
the entire industry just as the group
was starting to share the statement of
the world the organization began to
fracture and then implode over the past
several days more than half of the
National Book Critics Circle 24 board
members which had included six people of
color have resigned in a flurry of
acrimony shion's over racism privacy
concerns and political correctness
what exactly happened well the
organization's president when Laurie
Herzl who is white ran the statement by
several board members who hadn't
participated in writing it one board
member caralyn Romano said he disagreed
with some of the claims in the letter
but didn't want to distract from the
great majority of the board from its
mission but he went on to detail his
objections to a number of those claims
dismissing the statements fundamental
premise is absolute nonsense that the
publishing industry has been attempting
to silence the voices of people of color
which is absolute nonsense by the way I
mean it's just not true I know a lot of
the heads of these major publishing
corporations the last thing they're
attempting to do
is silence people of color it's insane I
mean fully insane a white critic and
former board president he took issue
with the idea the publishing business
operated with quote the full benefits of
white supremacy and institutional racism
and that white gatekeeping had been
working to stifle black voices at every
level of our industry these are
statements that were made in this little
letter and then she was chided and then
other people got angry and then a bunch
of people were basically forced to
resign from the National Book Critics
Circle we've seen data analysts who
worked for liberal organizations like
David Shore put out basically anodyne
data points and then be forced to resign
from organizations like civics analytics
Rosina we've seen high-level people
who've been forced to resign from their
jobs the Boeing communications chief was
forced to resign because 33 years ago he
wrote a piece saying that women
shouldn't be in direct combat right well
this stuff does exist and it's existed
for quite a long time I mean let's not
pretend that this is a creation of this
year I'm old enough to remember when
Brendon ice the co-founder of Mozilla
Firefox was forced to resign from his
position for the great sin of having
supported traditional marriage under
prop under the proposition in 2008 in
California that proposed the traditional
manner to be preserved by the way that
was at a time when Barack Obama
supported traditional marriage he was
forced resign Brendan Eich right so
cancel culture has been around for a
very very long time it has just picked
up a lot of speed and more and more it
is being applied to the common everyday
citizen it's not just being applied to
people at high levels of power and
prestige it is being applied to everyone
if you are a person who is working in a
corporation and you're at a very low
level and you have a Facebook post from
three years ago suggesting that hands up
don't shoot was a lie maybe you'll be
cancelled if you say all black lives
matter not just black lives matter you
could find yourself on the chopping
block if you point out that Robyn
D'Angelo is white fragility is a bag of
hogwash well then you are going to be
canceled probably so cancel culture
undoubtedly exists because we are
watching it every single day and if you
don't feel like hansel culture exists
it's because you're are ignorant or
you're a member of the persecuting party
there are a lot of people out there
particularly on the hard left or members
of the cancel culture who insist that
they are not actually part of a cancel
culture they're just holding people
accountable except they're not holding
people accountable because the
accountability is generally chiding
somebody for their bad behavior it's not
going to their employer and having them
fired over something that is absolutely
not fireable and has nothing to do with
their employment the difference between
cancel culture and regular court
I disagree with what you just said and
I'm gonna go to your boss and see with
your boss disagrees I just said cancel
culture is about trying to ruin
somebody's life over something they said
that you disagree with right that's the
definition of cancel culture it is not
just we are going to criticize what you
said we're not gonna point out that
you're wrong we're not gonna have a
conversation about that it is we're
going to go to all of the ways that you
make your money and make your living and
earn your bread and we are going to
attempt to deprive you of those things
because we disagree with the thing that
you just said and that is the nature of
cancel culture the great defenders of
cancel culture of course claim that it
doesn't exist so jut let them all writes
popular information which is this blog
that is specifically dedicated to going
after outlets on the right and very
often just making up information about
them
full disclosure he's been coming after
daily wire recently for the bizarre
claim that the way that we make our
money is by marketing via a third party
Facebook page that was responsible for
it counted one point zero one percent of
the grand total traffic in the last
three months via our analytics in any
case jeff Legum suggested quote cancel
culture is something that does not exist
but is a very popular concept among
people who do terrible things and don't
like being held accountable so cancel
culture doesn't exist and also I am the
leader of it right that statement said
cancel culture doesn't exist also I'm
just going to say that I'm going to ruin
your life in your career for you
disagree with me right who do terrible
things what are the terrible things that
are being done the terrible things that
are being done are typically things like
not being quote unquote anti-racist
enough in the in bro McKenzie definition
of anti racism I being too fragile
crying a white woman crying at a meeting
but these are things that are terrible
things and don't like being held
accountable Chuck led them says the
problem with the United States is not
that there is too much accountability
but there is too little too little
accountability
he says it's amazing the self-proclaimed
champions of free speech scream stop
criticizing me you are attacking free
speech every time they say something
pernicious and someone responds that is
the opposite of free speech if you
believe in free speech defend your
position
okay but this is this is what's larious
he then goes on to use as his example of
people or falsely or falsely claiming
canceled culture a case in which
somebody actually was cancelled right so
then he says so from from his little
screed here in which you suggest
canceled culture doesn't exist his
suggestion is if I say something and Jeb
welcome criticizes it and I call that
canceled culture no that's not canceled
culture canceled culture is when you
attempt to take me off the air because
you disagree with what I say but he's
fine with that too okay because his
exact example of something that his
quote unquote not canceled culture is
when the New Yorkers David Remnick
interview was supposed to interview
Steve Bannon at an event and then
canceled the actual interview because
there's so much blowback about Stieb and
that's an actual cancelling that's an
actual event that was cancelled okay
does not just somebody disagreed with
Steve Bannon it was you had booked an
event and then you cancelled the events
thanks to blowback so Chad Legum says
I'm just I'm taking back free speech
from this tiresome group of people who
just complained all the time about being
silenced but actually get paid lots of
money to say boring things know that
that know that do you not understand the
answer is he does understand English is
just a damned liar right I mean this is
this is what people do okay so it's not
just it's not just juggling them of
course there's a whole group of people
on the on the Left who say this sort of
stuff the canceled culture doesn't
actually exist now the reason this has
come up at this moment particularly is
not just because we've had a wave of
cancellations a tsunami of cancellations
coming for literally everyone I mean
they're now going after lin-manuel
Miranda and trying to he'll ruin his
career for the great sin of having
created a musical in which the founders
are played by people of color and he
didn't speak up loudly enough against
black lives matter I mean they're trying
to cancel lin-manuel Miranda not just
criticizing him they're trying to
basically suggests that maybe Hamilton
shouldn't be on things like Disney
applause right maybe we should remove
the mechanisms of dissemination there
are people who are actually doing this
hey everyone will be canceled if you are
not sufficiently on the left or if you
have not paid obeisance to the left it
would be very hard radical left then you
will be cancelled well a group of
academics stood up yesterday and they
said well we're not you know we don't
like this we're not into it
they issued a letter on justice and open
debate and this letter was signed by a
huge group of people from right left and
center
included people like Wynton Marsalis the
famous jazz musician and Applebaum who
certainly of the of the political left
is political liberal Margaret Atwood
right who's the writer of The Handmaid's
Tale and it extended to people like
Yasha
monk from the Atlantic it extended to
Olivia nosy at New York Magazine Nixon
Noam Chomsky all the way on the left
right a defender of Pol Pot and mere
Rouge Noam Chomsky was like I don't like
this stuff Nicholas Christakis who's the
Yale professor who was ousted from his
job for the great crime of it suggesting
that Halloween costumes were merely
Halloween costumes right he's signed on
the letter JK Rowling is on the letter
Salman Rushdie is on letter Jessie
single is on the letter from New York
formerly of New York magazine the list
is very very long Randi Weingarten the
head of the American Federation of
Teachers
Barry Weiss is on the list Sean
Weiland's from Princeton University is
on the list
Thomas Chatterton Williams was the
writer who is black who had created the
letter in the first place matthew
Yglesias
as we will see an important figure was
was on the list I can't name on the list
a single person who I believe voted for
Trump I think every single one of these
people so far as I can see is somebody
who did not vote for Trump but these are
all people who are on the political left
for the most part there may be one or
two exceptions but I'm hard-pressed to
find them maybe Francis Fukuyama maybe
but pretty much everybody else was on
this list is on the political left so
we're gonna get to the actual content to
the letter which has generated a
thousand backlashes
a thousand backlashes and we'll see how
it is an utterly uncontroversial letter
it seems almost like virtue signaling
it's like you guys were late on this
bandwagon guy some of us I've been
talking about this for quite a while
my friend Eric Weinstein who is famous
for for coming up with the term
intellectual dark web to describe a
group of people who just wanted to have
open conversations we took inordinate
incoming fire over this right four years
we took incoming fire over this she was
like welcome to the party pal okay so
we'll get to this letter in a second
because as you will see these same
people who are claiming their there is
no canceled culture are now attempting
to cancel the people who signed the
letter about the evils of canceled
culture
I'm not sure what's funnier people
claiming that there is no cancel culture
while simultaneously being key cogs in
cancel culture or people who sign this
letter they're been at least a couple we
signed this letter to cry and cancel
culture and then out of fear of
cancellation unsigned the letter hey
that that's been a thing that's been
going on we'll get to that in just one
second first let us talk about the fact
that hiring these days can be incredibly
difficult I mean how do you know who's
the best employee there's a best swab of
candidates and if you're a possible
employee how do you know you're gonna
get hired how's it possible to get hired
in an economy with this many people out
of work and attempting to get back into
the workforce this is why you need it
zip recruiter hiring can be difficult
but if you're a company that's currently
trying to hire you face new difficulties
from safely reopening at your doors to
finding the right person for a
specialized role
we here at daily wear have been using
zip recruiter for years to accomplish
just this purpose and find the best
employees it also keeps our own
employees on their toes so let's say
that you screwed up the booking of a
guest like producer Katy and let's
suggest that producer Katy we had to
find a replacement zip recruiter would
be the first place that we would look
housing wired could relate they needed
to hire an ambitious reporter to cover
news stories on the u.s. mortgage and
housing market so they turned to zip
recruiter and that's how they found
Alexandra Roja Alexandra never imagined
she could get a reporter job in the
midst of the Cova 19 crisis because
hiring with frozen and the idea of
looking for a job was discouraging she
created a profile on zip recruiter and
her employer found her she found the
right job and zip recruiter helped
housing where to find the right person
for their role fast see how zip
recruiter can help you hire try it now
for free at zip recruiter comm slash
daily wire at is zip recruiter comm
slash daily wired check them out right
now zip recruiter comm slash daily wire
okay so this letter from Harper's is
what has generated in the ordinate
controversy what exactly does this
letter what does this letter say it says
our cultural institutions are facing a
moment of trial powerful protests for
racial and social justice are leading to
overdue demands for police reform along
with wider calls for greater equality
and inclusion across our society not
least in higher education journalism of
philanthropy and the arts but this
needed reckoning has also intensified a
new set of moral attitudes and political
commitments that tend to weaken our
norms of open debate and toleration of
differences in favor of ideological
conformity as we applaud the first
development we also raised our voices
against the second the forces of the
liberalism are gaining strength
throughout the world and have a powerful
ally in Donald Trump represents here
threat to democracy but resistance must
not be allowed to harden into its own
brand of dogma / or coercion which
right-wing demagogues are already
exploiting see the letter is so
apologetic about the point that it's
making I think we don't want to find
ourselves on the same side of this issue
as you know tucker carlson or ben
shapiro we don't want to find ourselves
on the same set but that's where we find
ourselves and the right-wing demagogues
are exploiting the fact it's all about
the pouncing the right-wing remember
these are all liberals signing this the
right-wing is exploiting the fact the
cancel culture exists and this is why we
have to fight against cancel culture you
know who's really bad Donald Trump is
also really bad sound Trump has he's a
powerful ally of liberalism okay Donald
Trump has not done anything to stop free
speech in the United States of America
nothing nothing zero things as Donald
Trump done to stop the free speech in
America the Democratic conclusion we
want can be achieved only if we speak
out against the intolerant climate this
has set on all sides so this is very
tepid statement right it's very tepid
statement from the center left to the
left the free exchange of information
and ideas the lifeblood of liberal
society is daily becoming more
constricted
well we have come to expect this on the
radical right since seriousness is also
spreading more widely in our culture
okay I love this
it's the again the entire letter is
about how we have to keep saying the
right the right the right the right okay
the free exchange of information ideas
let me let you know secret folks the
right has not been complicit in this for
a long time
the notion that the right unless you're
talking about like a radical radical
right like you're talking about like the
aunt right or white supremacist or
something if you're talking about like
the mainstream right attempting to shut
down the free exchange of information
ideas that has not been a thing for a
very long time which is why so many
people on the Left have been texting me
from their unique perches at major media
institutions going why am I on your side
why what's going on and I'm saying to
them like listen if you get fired I'll
help you find a job they're coming to me
okay it's not the other way around I've
been standing over here with this flag
for quite a while with guys you don't
get to go well you know the radical
right normally normally does this sort
of stuff but we've been perturbed to
find the left doing this sort of set
guys maybe that was true in like 1966
okay it is not true in 2020 and it
hasn't been true for a very long time
since Orias left those are the people
who are attempting to shut down my
speeches on college campuses or go after
my advertisers or shut down shows like
mine or shut down shows on Fox News or
shut down Rush Limbaugh right that is
what they like what are you talking
about I love this too this creation
listen I'm not even a fan of this letter
okay but the letter goes on right they
say well we have come to expect this on
the radical right sensoria sness is also
spreading more widely in our culture and
intolerance of opposing views a vogue
for public shaming and ostracism and the
tendency to dissolve complex policy
issues in blinding moral certainty we
have pulled the value of robust and even
caustic counter speech from all quarters
but it is now all too common to hear
calls for swift and severe retribution
in response to perceived transgressions
of speech and thought not troubling
still institutional leaders in a spirit
of panic to damage control are
delivering hasty and disproportionate
punishments instead of considered
reforms editors are fired for running
controversial pieces that's referenced
to the New York Times op-ed editor who
is fired fronting in time cotton piece
books are withdrawn for alleged
inauthenticity that is a reference to a
novel called American dirt in which a
woman who was I believe not a Latina
extraction
she wrote a novel about illegal
immigration and it was considered very
very bad because she was not actually an
illegal immigrant
journalists are barred from writing on
certain topics which happens all the
time professors are investigated for
quoting works of litter
in class has happened several times a
researcher is fired for circulating a
peer-reviewed academic study that we
David Shore the heads of organizations
are ousted what are sometimes just
clumsy mistakes that Bibi op-ed editor
the Philadelphia Inquirer or the head of
bone Appetit or the or the guy who is
there trying to now ask from his perch
over at the southern food group or
whatever it is who had committed the
great sin of being a white guy whatever
the arguments around each particular
incident the result has been to steadily
narrow the boundaries of what can be
said without threat of reprisal we're
already paying the price in greater risk
aversion among writers artists and
journalists who fear for their
livelihoods if they depart from the
consensus or even lack sufficient zeal
in agreement this cycling atmosphere
will ultimately harm the most vital
causes of our time the restriction of
debate whether by a repressive
government or an intolerant society
invariably hurts those who lack power it
makes everyone less capable of
democratic participation is all the
letter and Harper signed by again a bevy
of people who are on the left like a
huge solicit maybe 150 people again not
a single one voted for Trump the way to
defeat bad ideas is by exposure argument
and persuasion not by trying to silence
or wish them away we refuse any false
choice between justice and freedom which
cannot exist without each other as
writers we need a culture that leaves us
room for experimentation risk-taking and
even mistakes we need to preserve the
possibility of good-faith disagreement
without dire professional consequences
if we won't defend the very thing on
which our work depends we shouldn't
expect the public or the states to
defend it for us
except for all of the bizarre kind of
slaps at the right that are just virtue
signaling nonsense to their left his
friends don't worry guys we're still on
your side we still agree except for all
of that this is basically just reality I
mean that is just the reality and that
is why you have people ranging from on
the right people like Deirdre McCloskey
all the way to folks like no I'm Chomsky
on the far left right David Brooks and
and no I'm Chomsky Steven Pinker and
aunt Elfie Brahim right I mean at a very
large swath of the laughs right Malcolm
Gladwell all the way to people like
Gloria Steinem and nadine strossen and
so that that's a very big list of people
who are again center to left
what the blowback has been intense and
not shocking not shocking and we'll get
to that blowback in just one second
because it is so telling about where we
are and society that letter which is
pretty straightforwardly of the left
again has it the requisite slaps against
Trump in the requisite slats and it
slaps against the radical rides and the
evil conservatives and all this stuff
that letter is now being ripped up by
the hard political left and in an
attempt to prove the cancel culture
doesn't exist and or is being
exaggerated people on the list are now
coming under pressure to be canceled for
having signed the letter which is just
perfect it's just perfect
culture doesn't exist says the man is he
tries to Club you into submission that's
where we are right now we'll get some
more of this in just one second first
let's talk about the fact that you are
listening to an awful lot of media right
now you're listening to shows like this
when you need a great pair of wireless
earbuds
everyone needs a great pair of wireless
earbuds before you go dropping hundreds
of bucks on a pair you need to check out
the wireless earbuds from Ray Khan you
already know ray Khan earbuds start at
about half the price of any other
premium wireless earbuds on the market
and if they sound just as amazing as
other top audio brands you know their
newest model the everyday e25 year buds
are the best ones yet six hours of
playtime seamless bluetooth pairing more
bass a more compact design that gives
you a nice noise isolating fit ray cons
wireless earbuds are so comfortable they
are perfect for conference calls or
binging podcasts unlike some of your
other wireless options ray con earbuds
are both silent discreet no dangling
wires or stems to distract anyone during
video calls pick up a pair see what the
hype is all about and they fit perfectly
on your ear one of the beautiful things
about ray cons they're not
one-size-fits-all they have a variety of
fit you can put directly in your ear now
is the time to get the latest and
greatest from Ray Khan get 15% off your
order at bu IR a YCL ENCOM slash man by
Raycom slash man that is by Raycom / Ben
for 15% off ray Conner wireless earbuds
again by Ray Khan calm / Mannion go
check them out right now and get 15% off
your order by raike on.com slash
then hey so the blowback on this letter
is intense and huge right the radical
left is like I can't even believe that
people would say that cancel culture is
bad because what the radical left has
been hoping to do is again push and then
gain adherence simply through
intimidation tactics it's like a
snowball you start this enou ball effect
you can sort of get people to stay
silent and then once they've stayed
silent then you can compel them to
repeat the Nostrum so you want them to
repeat and then you can get them to
become part of the mob because better to
be part of mob than to be eaten by the
mob and so here you have an obstacle to
the mob mentality that is now formed on
the radical left to cancel everybody who
disagrees and so you're seeing
journalists reporters or like you know
what his letters real bad
letters real bad Felicia sign meze
Washington Post national political
reporter here's what she wrote she said
there's definitely a debate to be had
about ordinary people whose lives are
turned upside down by a viral moment a
phenomenon that's happening more and
more these days he's not just happening
it's being pushed my places like The
Washington Post and The New York Times
we
how many incidents have we seen they've
been blown up into national stories that
are not even local news rather that that
whole story about the woman in the bird
park who had a racially tinged
conversation but I was kind of nasty a
racially tinged conversation with the
black bird-watching guy right that was a
national story that ran for like five
days on the front page of the New York
Times so don't tell me that this stuff
is just sort of happening it's not just
sort of happening sometimes the
consequences are warranted and sometimes
they're not each case is different
suspicious on mez but high profile
cancellations such as the ones alluded
to in the harper's letter are a
different beast and it's disingenuous to
describe them in such innocuous terms as
the letter does it's not about free
speech it's about words and actions that
harm the vulnerable and this is the line
of cancel culture well I know cancel
culture some of us have been describing
this for years so it's a point of high
irritation to people like me who've been
calling this out for literally years and
exactly the tactics that they are using
and now people are starting to come
around be like nah that's that the
either saying no that's it that's not
real or explicitly saying the thing I've
been saying they're saying hey I give us
I gave testimony in Congress in the
Congressional Record and which I
explicitly talked about the attempt to
treat speech as violence right they when
I was when I was at Berkeley people were
literally chanting speech is violence
because the idea is that if I say
something that is that you don't like I
have done it violence to you I've macro
aggressive and therefore you're allowed
to perform physical violence on me and
or harm me or my career right that is
what you're allowed to do because my
words hurt your feelings and if I hurt
your feelings I've done you harm its
words or actions that harm the
vulnerable now the beautiful thing about
that standard is there is no way to
disprove it because
do you prove that words her mul knurl
when we were all kids we used to hear
sticks and stones may break your bones
but words may never hurt me but we have
decided to know that words aren't actual
weapons words are things that hurt you
and if something hurts you you're
allowed to fight back the proper
response to being hurt is to punch back
and terror and to defend yourself and
thus canceling someone and ruining their
career or ruining their life getting
getting them fired for no apparent
reason oh you're doing this defend
yourself from a farm and this is again a
Washington Post a national political
reporter not a not bad editor and she
says a key component to the whole notion
of canceled culture seems to be the
denial or dismissal of that very harm as
though sexual assault racial epithets
and the marginalization of trans people
were all frivolous things just part of
some intellectual exercise okay hold on
you just lump together
sexual assault and the quote unquote
marginalization of trans people if you
are now ik waiting an attempted rape
with I used the proper biological
pronoun to describe a person I have a
feeling that you are the problem here
intellectually that's it that's a
horrifying equation instead of thinking
of the canceled as figures whose merits
and flaws can be weighed in a vacuum
why not view them within the context in
which they actually exist as figures
whose actually may be putting their
co-workers or students or others around
them at risk ah so here now we get to
the crux right we can't say actually
view people with their merits and flaws
in a vacuum we can't view them as
individuals we in the name of social
justice we have to view them for the
impacts their words have had this is one
of the nostrils of the social justice
movement one of the Nostrum says that
intent doesn't matter only effect
matters so if you say something
perfectly innocuous and somebody else
feels harmed by that that is still your
fault this is one of the key points of
the anti racism white fragility movement
so that absolutely in table
right there that's Washington Post
national political reporter so part of
the blowback is you don't get to claim
anything about canceled culture because
absolutely you're hurting people with
your speech your speech is hurting
people so your cancel cancel culture is
good it's not just it's not just it both
exists it both does not exist and it's
also good is the argument that is being
made right now it doesn't exist but also
if it is happening it's because it's not
canceled culture it's just awesomeness
and get to more of this and the blowback
and the predictable and the predictable
walk back from some of the people who
signed the letter in just a second first
let's talk about the fact that now is
not a great time to go to the auto parts
art in fact you know what it's really
never a great time to go to the auto
parts store instead you should be
checking out rockauto.com rockauto.com
is really easy a lot easier than walking
into a store and someone's demanding
quick answers to things like is your
Odyssey and LX or NEX and then they
usually just have to order the part
online anyway because there are so many
types of cars it's impossible to keep
them all stocked you have access to
rockauto.com at your desk in your pocket
rockauto.com they always offer the
lowest prices possible rather than
changing prices based on what the market
will bear like Airlines - I spend up to
twice as much or at the same parts
rockauto.com is a family business
serving Auto Parts customers online for
20 years go to rockauto.com shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers best of all prices at
rockauto.com are always reliably low and
the same for professionals and
do-it-yourselfers I spend up to twice as
much before the same parts the
rockauto.com catalog is unique
remarkably easy to navigate quickly see
all the parts available for your vehicle
choose the brands specifications and
prices you prefer if that amazing
selection it reliably low prices and all
the parts your car will ever need Rock
Auto calm again head on over to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car truck right
Shapiro in there how did you hear about
us box so they know that we sent you
okay so the blowback again continues a
journalist for The New York Times in
Varanasi he she writes the letter right
this Harper's letter was shaped slash
spearheaded from conversations by for a
privileged white men apparently they
felt entitled it's really weigh in on
racism diversity and inclusion that says
it all um actually some of the key
figures it was spearheaded by a writer
at Thomas Jefferson Williams it was a
black man so that is not actually true
but again cancel the letter because too
many white people involved too many
white people involved and then the
canceling will continue apace
Matthew Iglesias who I am not a fan of
as you will recall I have referred to
him on the show repeatedly as the Ralph
Wiggum of the internet so I'm I do not
think you can count me in the Iglesias
fan pack Hey how far is left gone they
forced me into now defending Matthew
Iglesias so well done everybody all the
way around just really well done stuff
there's a writer named Emily vanderwerff
was a transwoman which is to say a
biological man who says she is one who
says he is a woman hey and she and this
person writes to the editors of ox it
tries to go over the head of Matthew
Iglesias report of what the editors of
ox came to the editors as a trans woman
who very much values for position at Fox
and the support the publication has
given her through the emotional and
physical turmoil of transition I was
deeply saddened to see Matt Iglesias his
signature on the Harper's Weekly letter
now you may be saying yourself wait a
second trans stuff isn't even mentioned
in that letter like I just read the
entire text of the letter to you out
loud not once our trans issues mentioned
not a single solitary time but says
Emily vanderwerff Matt is of course
entitled to his own opinion I know he's
a more nuanced thinker than signing the
letter would suggest thinner more
nuanced thinker is just a suggestion
that he didn't really know what you were
signing there's no nuance to let her
know there is nuance to the letter you
just don't like what the letter says
well I just say it write more you're not
nuanced enough is a way for somebody on
the left to basically sneer at you in
derision and paternalistic concern for
your stupidity and so Emily vanderwerff
again this was written too mad at Glacia
sat the editor is it at the advice where
he's co-founder right has never been
anything but kind to me and has often
supported my work publicly all of which
I'm extremely grateful for but but the
letter signed as it is by several
prominent anti-trans voices and
containing as many dog whistles sort of
anti-trans positions as it does ideally
would not have been signed by anybody at
Vox much less one of the most prominent
people at our publication again Matt's
opinions and experiences are his own he
can do what he wants with his free time
but his signature being on the letter
makes me feel less safe at box ah there
it is there it is
all you have to do is just wait for it
for like seven sentences eight sentences
every time every time they cancel
culture warriors they go - oh I feel
unsafe you know what you should do you
should really start something I think
you can call it maybe like the Committee
on Public Safety you can call it the
Committee on Public Safety and then you
can just go around canceling people and
if you don't really it really if you got
a problem you just behead them in fact
like the Committee on Public Safety
which was a four
we're not hitting the reference this
ended in an overt reference to the
French Revolution the Committee of
Public Safety was the provisional
government of France during the reign of
terror that's why I'm making the
reference you can call it the Committee
on Public Safety because your safety has
been threatened don't you see you've
been threatened by the fact that Mathieu
Iglesias signed on to an extraordinarily
anodyne letter about the evils of
council culture and you can say well you
know as a trans woman I now feel
threatened so the letter can
simultaneously suggest that the person
that you're writing about quote has
never been anything but kind to me and
has often supported my work publicly but
also his opinion that makes me feel less
safe so so unsafe so much unsafe miss
happening well they used the exact same
excuse by the way for firing Kevin
Williamson at the Atlantic right they
hired Kevin Williamson at the Atlantic
and then a bunch of feminists said I
feel unsafe that Kevin Williamson has
been hired at the Atlantic he said in
like his he's sitting on his house in in
Texas you never met any of these people
like I feel so unsafe I'm feeling so
unsafe really did you send a death
threat to you did you leave like an
anonymous phone call on your phone what
exactly did he do what did mad at
Glacius do to emily vanderwerff did you
call this person up on their phone and
say I think that you are a biological
man and therefore I dismiss your
existence like what exactly is the big
threatening thing Matt Iglesias did he
didn't say anything about trans stuff
Matt Iglesias agrees with this person on
trans policies he's written about it
extensively okay look what are you what
but apparently it's a threat to safety
for this person to even appear on a list
of people like JK Rowling as JK Rowling
said wow that's really what this letter
is this particular blowback is about JK
Rowling who said that biological women
exist which by the way is not a
threatening position I'm sorry it is not
a threat to your safety for me to point
out that a biological man is in fact a
biological man and not a woman okay that
is not a threat to your safety I'm not
saying anything bad should happen to you
I think anybody who tries to threaten
you should go to jail right the law
applies to you just as it applies to
everyone else but the idea is if you
disagree with you if you make me feel
lesser if you make me feel bad then
you've threatened my safety and you have
threatened my safety your words are more
damaging than me ruining your career or
going or going to the editors at your
publication and publicly it's back by
the way let me just say this Matt
Iglesias you're the co-founder of box if
somebody at my organization said
something like this
like put out a public letter suggesting
that I had threatened their safety for
an opinion of mine
it'll be out on their ass the next day I
would fire them the next day the next
day because let me explain I run my
publication okay and I'm not gonna take
crap from staffers who believe that
opinions are threatening to safety I'm
not gonna be accused of threatening
someone's safety for signing onto an
anodyne opinion about how council
culture is generally bad
Emily vanderwerff says his signature on
the letter makes me feel less safe at
box and believe slightly less in its
stated goals of building more diverse in
more thoughtful workplace on a more
practical level the presence of math
suites and his signature to a letter
like this do make my job slightly more
difficult do they do they really as it
would be readers and sources who often
equate my positions with his after all
he remains one of our most prominent
staffers I don't want Matt to be
reprimands or fired or even asked to
submit an apology doing any of the above
would only solidify in his own mind the
idea that he's being martyred for his
beliefs but I do want to make clear that
those beliefs cost him nothing they are
not particularly risky they're not
particularly sound even I'm used to
hearing them from people who believe my
own lived experiences pale in comparison
to their own momentary social media
discomfort I'm sorry to find that among
those voices okay and no point that a
Glacia is compare his experiences in
life to this Emily under more character
I mean it's just it's amazing it's
amazing so calling out Matthew Iglesias
publicly these Matthew Glacius was bad
enough to sign this letter it well this
this sort of pressure which is bubbled
up again there's nothing in the letter
it's about trans people not a single
thing in the letter in fact the letter
basically says we are members of the
left we support if you just read that
letter in any objective way what you
would come away with is they support all
of the propaganda put forth by the trans
movement generally right JK Rowling is
on the letter because it doesn't make
that explicit but the whole thing is
about social justice and equality and we
hate Trump and all of this like if you
just read that letter without knowing
any of the signatories there's no way
you could possibly come away with the
opinion that the people who wrote that
letter do anything except support the
idea that a biological man can become a
woman right I mean that just does not
exist in the text of the letter but
what's hilarious is that there are these
tweets that are going around things like
one of the things you should think about
in that letter are are you responsible
for the actions and opinions of people
who are also signatories to the letter
should we assume that if you're mad at
Glacius you now agree with JK Rowling on
trans issues of course not that's the
stupidest thing I've ever heard in my
entire life
should we assume that Matthew Iglesias
is also a Cambodian genocide denier like
Noam Chomsky like no if I sign on to a
letter with a bunch of other people the
text of the letter is what we have in
common okay that's it is nothing else
there is no way to compute any other
agreements on any other issue other than
the letter that we have commonly signed
right there
what in the world but what does this
result and it results in people starting
to pull down their support so one of the
original signatories was a person named
Jennifer Finney Boylan who's a trans
person a Trent I believe Jenna correct I
believe that Jennifer I'm gonna look it
up just to make sure but Jennifer Finney
Boylan writes for The New York Times and
is in fact a Trent yeah a transgender
activist professor at Barnard College of
a Columbia University and this person
put out a statement quote I did not know
who else had signed that letter I
thought I was endorsing a well-meaning
if vague message against internet
shaming I didn't know Chomsky Steinem an
Atwood were in and I thought good
company first of all this demonstrates
your perspective when you think that
Noam Chomsky is good company and Gloria
Steinem is great company but says
Jennifer Finney Boylan the consequences
are mind to bear I am so sorry I'm so
sorry so out of fear of being canceled
and being ostracized by the trans rights
community a trans person we signed on to
the letter now has to now has to
apologize hey then there's a person
named Kerry Greenidge Kerry greenage is
one of the signatories and I believe is
the Mellon assistant professor in the
department of studies of race
colonialism and diaspora at Tufts
University and so this is a person very
much I've left so Kerry Greenidge signed
the letter and then wrote in a tweet I
do not endorse this harper's letter i'm
in contact with harper's about a
retraction so people are now walking
this stuff back right
walk it back because the blowback
canceled culture isn't real and also you
will be canceled if you sign a letter
saying the canceled culture is real
really well done everyone
really well done well get to more of
this by the way there's a whole cadre of
people who'll never be cancelled we'll
get to the cadre of people will never be
cancelled in just a second and I'll
point out a couple of outstanding
instances of how canceled culture comes
for us all like death and taxes in just
one second first if you've been
listening to the show for a while you've
heard me talk about my helix sleep
mattress the only thing that allows me
to last the day considering my children
wake me up ninety three times a night so
exciting news helix has gone beyond the
bedroom and they've started making sofas
which is awesome sauce it just launched
a new company called all form and making
premium customizable sofas and chairs
shipped directly to your door so what
makes an offer for himself a really cool
well for starters it's the easiest way
you can customize the sofa using premium
materials at a fraction of the cost of
traditional stores we have an offer for
him sofa and it is customizable and you
can bolt units onto it it is very easy
to put together and man it's durable
which is fantastic for me
you pick your fabric it spills stain and
scratch resistant the sofa color the
color of the legs that sofa size the
shape to make sure it is perfect for you
and your home you're spending off a lot
of time on your couch these days cuz
you're at home well all form sofas can
make your life so much more comfortable
and so much better all foam sofas are
delivered directly to your home with
fast free shipping in the past if you
wanted to order a sofa it could take
weeks or even months to arrive and you
would need someone to come and assemble
it in your home all for him takes just
three to seven days to arrive and mail
you can assemble it yourself in just a
few minutes with no tools necessary I've
gotten all for himself we got the three
seat sofa with the chaise in the sand
color with espresso legs it's beautiful
it's wonderful my kids love it my wife
loves it to find your perfect sofa
check out all form comm slash been an
all foam is offering 20% off all orders
for our listeners which is a great deal
all for Mom slash Ben go check them out
right now all form a LOF ORM calm sigh
spending at 20% off all orders the couch
is fantastic it's great sofa by the same
people do helix you're gonna love it
you really well go check them out right
now by the way you don't have to worry
if you don't love it because you got a
hundred days to decide if you want to
keep it which is more than three months
and they'll pick it up for free and give
you a refund if you don't so really this
is a great deal the same way he looks
sleep mattress is a great deal I
guarantee you this is great to find that
perfect sofa check out all forum comm
slash them okay we're gonna get into
more of the cancel culture that
apparently isn't real but also is so
real too
are afraid of saying that it's an saying
that's real well you if you say
Beetlejuice three times cancel culture
appears is basically how this goes we're
gonna get to that in just one second
first if you're not already its Hayley
why remember you should consider getting
a readers past as a Lee Weyer calm it is
a great value for only three bucks a
month when you sign up you get that
first month for only 99 cents they also
get access to our mobile app articles
have free access to exclusive editorials
like this one Star Trek's stealth
conservatism 11 classic episodes the
whoa crowd would cancel today by our
friend at Christian at toto so if you
haven't checked out the readers pass
already head on over to daily wire comm
and sign up for just a dollar you're
listening to the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
you
okay so how about is canceled culture
cancel culture is so bad that we have
now cancelled acting and also research
these are a couple things that we have
cancelled but don't worry it doesn't
exist and if you mentioned it exists
then you are a threat to somebody else's
safety there are threats of somebody
else's safety so how do we just cancel
acting well we've had in the past
what couple of years several
high-profile actresses who have been
told that they are not allowed to play
trans people and if you want to cast a
trans person the person has to be trans
so in other words let's say that you
want to play a trans man which means a
biological woman who believes that that
she is a male let's say that you want to
play that and you are a biological woman
which seems like it checks most of the
marks for playing a biological woman
like last I checked playing a biological
woman who believes she's a man that
seems like you should be able to play
that if you're a biological woman
correct like just putting it out there
all right that's like saying you have a
black person who believes in a
particular cause so if you're a black
person you should be able to play that
person even if you don't necessarily
believe in that political closet I mean
that that's called thing guys okay so
but here you can fulfill the physical
criteria
and because again biological woman
playing biological woman so apparently
not we've had a couple of situations in
the recent past in which this has not
been the case
first of all just pointing out from
Hollywood's perspective if you are not a
trans person and you play a trans person
in any iteration win an Oscar or Elise
nominated for one right surely don't
want an Oscar like a couple of years ago
for Dallas buyers club playing a trans
person and I believe Eddie Redmayne was
was nominated for an Oscar for playing a
trans person a couple of years ago so
it's pretty much gold ticket to Oscar
him but not anymore not anymore now it's
all stopped Scarlett Johansson you'll
recall about a year ago was supposed to
play a trans person in a movie those I
think called rub-and-tug
or something and the movie was canceled
because Scarlett Johansson is in fact a
woman a biological woman who does not
believe that she is a biological man and
therefore not trans hey Halle Berry just
went through the same thing so Halle
Berry was about to be cast in a story
about a trans man meaning a biological
woman and now she's pulled out of this
her is the statement she released with
the full malice struggle session
attached this is the best acting frankly
that Halle Berry has done since monster
monsters balls right here in this
statement first of all I'm also gonna
need an explanation on why Halle Berry
was able to play in x-men character when
she's fat she's in fact not a mutant if
she actually is not a mutant and yet
she's playing a mutant who can shoot
lightning from her from her fingertips
I'm gonna need like an explanation as to
the bigotry against lightning fingertips
mutants anyway Halle Berry says over the
weekend I had the opportunity to discuss
my consideration of an upcoming role as
a transgender man I'd like to apologize
for those remarks as a cisgender woman I
now understand I should not have
considered this role and that the
transgender community should undeniably
have the opportunity to tell their own
stories okay by the way this is now two
oscar-winning actresses who would have
greatly increased the profile of the
trans movement who have now been
cancelled or even considering these
roles I'm grateful for the guidance and
critical conversations over the past few
days and I will continue to listen
educate and learn from this mistake man
these now struggle sessions they are
they are not entertaining I will say
that I vowed to be an ally in using my
voice from a better representation on
screen both in front of and behind the
camera so acting is now against the law
we can we can
we can only have by the way I'm about to
make a joke but it's not actually a job
we can only have somebody who's a
quadriplegic play a quadriplegic that's
a thing that actually was discussed
right about Ballack breaking bad guy
right breaking bad guy was supposed to
what's his name name of the actor Brian
hunter and Bryan Cranston
he plays a quadriplegic in a movie and
people like why didn't you cast an
actual quadriplegic because it's acting
you idiots
we're now cancelling acting well they're
casting upcoming Peter Pan and a friend
of mine online Steven Miller not the one
who works for Trump Stephen Miller
tweeted out what why exactly are we
considering somebody who isn't naturally
hook-handed to play Captain Hook he's
apparently they're considering Jude Law
to play Captain Hook he's been cast but
captain he doesn't know the pain of
having to live with an actual hook hand
we need to cast somebody who actually
has a hook Brad and we need like the guy
that we need that that cleric from
London there's a hook for a hand to play
Captain Hook that's the only way that we
can really make this thing happen it's
just incredible so everyone will be
canceled the canceled culture comes for
everyone Halle Berry is canceled other
people or cancel so Princeton University
they have they have a group of faculty
who are now demanding I'm not kidding
you a committee to investigate research
and publications for racism hey this is
crazy and by the way the sort of stuff
does exist already we've seen cases in
which Brown University for example hold
down a full-on study about rapid onset
gender dysphoria because there were so
many people to school her mad at the
research the research was bad she had to
pull it down because there was somebody
there who pointed out by correctly that
there's been a rapid rise in the number
of young females who are identifying as
trans and it seems to be run run this
mentality seems to run roughshod from
small social groups he have one girl
with a bunch of friends they all have
other problems and one of the girls says
I'm trans and suddenly many of them are
saying they're trans rapid onset gender
dysphoria it's fairly well substantiated
at this point this researcher from Brown
had her study pulled down and the school
basically apologized for the study so
research was being censored we're
singing out my friend Abigail Schreyer
graduate of Yale Law
hey Abigail Abigail wrote a book about
rapid onset gender dysphoria and amazon
quickly sends her to any advertisement
for it a research is now being silent so
the on July 4th a roughly 4,000 word
open letter signed by hundreds of
members of the Princeton University
faculty was sent to the president
Provost Dean's and members of the
cabinet of the university listing a
series of demands related to racial
justice including a committee composed
entirely of faculty that would oversee
the investigation and discipline of
racist behaviors incidents research and
publication on the part of faculty so
now you're going to have a racially
diverse Committee on Public Safety over
at Princeton University that is going to
go through and decide what sort of
research is okay what sort of research
is okay
of actions also demanded acknowledged
credit and intensifies anti-racist
student activism such acknowledgement
should at a minimum take the form of
repair or reparative action beginning
with a formal public university apology
to the members of the Black Justice
League and their allies other demands
include nominating no fewer than two
faculty members of color for annual
elections 2 C 3 C 7 and committees on
diversity commit to anti-racist campus
iconography beginning with the removal
of the John wither since Witherspoon
statute Wetherspoon is considered maybe
the founder of Princeton University but
he held slaves and therefore we have to
remove the statue
and then the letter concludes we
understand some of these suggestions are
implementable now others will require
more time to enact we would be grateful
for the opportunity to meet with you to
discuss the measures and actions
proposed to rent and expedience timeline
so again the worst demand here is that
they're going to constitute committee
composed entirely of faculty that would
oversee the investigation and discipline
of racist behaviour racism is not
defined in this document for grievance
and appeal to be spelled out in rules
and procedures of the faculty guidelines
on what counts as racist behavior
incidents research and publication will
be authored by a faculty committee for
incorporation into the same set of rules
and procedures so in other words my ADA
grants a blank check that we can call
racist whomever we want and shut down
and shut down anybody who participates
in behavior we now deem as racist
including research and publication ok if
you think that this is not a threat to
freedom of thought and freedom its
feature out of your mind or out of your
mind and thus I will admit that I am
grateful for the simple fact if you are
in a position of public power and just
say no just say no to cancel culture
guys just like you should have said no
to drugs in the nineteen eighties just
say no to cancel cultures if your
prominent enough you can say no and you
know what nobody can do anything about
it
JK Rowling saying no is important
because she refused to be cancelled and
thus she has not cancelled you know who
else they're trying to cancel these days
of course Zuckerberg over at Facebook so
they're these organizations leftist
left-wing organizations or attempting to
shut the door to free speech on Facebook
by basically trying to club
organizations but big corporations into
pulling their advertisement from
Facebook until Facebook restrict speech
to the preferred forms of speech that
are approved by wild leftist groups like
the ADL and Color of Change
the group's had a get-together with Mark
Zuckerberg and Sheryl Sandberg over at
Facebook trying to basically blackmail
into changing Zuckerberg position on
free speech I distinguishes Zuckerberg
from the other leaders of these of these
groups because Zuckerberg has openly
committed to free speech and he's not
taken the sort of censorious positions
of many of these other social media
leaders I mean it's been very public
about this but apparently civil rights
leaders called meeting very
disappointing and blasted Facebook for
being functionally flawed in a media
call after the meeting where Schad
robinson head of color of change said of
facebook's executives they showed up to
the meeting expecting an A for
attendance attending alone is not enough
Facebook said in a statement the groups
want Facebook to be free of hate speech
and so do we
they said they were taking the steps to
keep hate off the platform they said we
know we'll be judged by our actions that
not bad words but bottom line is that
once you cave once you start keeping to
the woke social justice warriors they
expect you to constantly cave right it
never stops you'll be rolled into the
snowball and the snowball we push
downhill you just have to go along with
all of this I'll point out at Facebook
refusing to go along with all of this
it's having no impact on stock price is
why I say you can just say no to cancel
culture you can and you should investors
are not worried about the advertisers
boycotting Facebook the fact is from
what I understand Facebook actually
makes most of its money because small
businesses use it for advertising not
because you have major corporations
dropping a couple mil Hillar here or
there on advertising Facebook shares hit
an all-time high for the company on the
same day that they were being boycotted
so cancel culture doesn't actually work
right that's the dirty little secret is
that unless you are a low-level employee
and can actually be bullied into being
fired right then cancel culture doesn't
work all these organizations have to do
is just say no we're not gonna do it
we're not gonna do it
you're only cancelled if you agree to be
canceled there's there's one other group
of people who are never canceled and
that is if your radical left enough
nothing you do will ever be even called
up for question by the canceled culture
because the right does not have the
capacity to cancel the left and the left
does not have the capacity to cancel the
right so ironically enough the people
who are most vulnerable are the people
in the center of our politics so if
you're a centrist and you are working in
a left-wing organization
chat you get canceled if you're a right
winger you're probably not working in a
left-wing organization right you're
vulnerable if you work for a left-wing
organization but right-wingers and left
wingers have basically self polarized at
this point so that means people in the
center are the most vulnerable if you're
on the right and you're in your living
being on the right you're not gonna get
cancelled by the right if you're on the
left and you're on your living from the
left the right has no capacity to cancel
you and the left doesn't care about
cancelling you because anything and
everything you do and say that is bad
and terrible it's perfectly acceptable
right you'll never be canceled ever and
the agenda never stops on the radical
left because let's be real about this
cancel culture is just the is just the
club with which the social justice
warriors who hope to remould all of
American society in their image beat
people into submission that's all that's
happening here and the crusade is very
clear right the goal here is very very
obvious so Chama Salman was a socialist
city council member of Seau she was
considered an oddity way back when when
I was doing a Sean Casey th radio Sean
Casey th back in 2014 she was mostly
considered just this kooky oddity we
said weird things about how we need to
demilitarize Boeing and we're gonna
occupy Boeing and all this kind of crazy
crap she was pushing $15 minimum wage
and now she has considered sort of a a
rabble-rousing leader on the Seattle
City Council she made clear immediately
after basically you know getting chided
by Mayor Jenny zirkon for trying to lead
a revolution after passing an Amazon tax
which has a head tax and Amazon
employees which will help drive Amazon
out of the city Shona Solomon said I'm
coming for all the fortune 500 companies
we're coming after all of them and we're
coming after capitalism generally the
agenda is pretty obvious here it has
nothing to do with making the country
better and everything to do with
overthrowing the system entirely we are
fighting for far more than this tax we
are preparing the ground for a different
kind of society and if you Jeff Bezos
want to drive that process forward by
lashing out against us in our modest
demands then so be it because we are
coming for you and your rotten system we
are coming to dismantle this deeply
oppressive racist sexist violent utterly
bankrupt system of capitalism this
police state she's never gonna be
cancelled because for the left none of
this is cancelable right what counts as
a cancelable offense is the big question
here the left things that unite counts
it's cancelable offenses include
everything in America should be torn
down or out in your ears and also maybe
violent criminal activity I mean the
left won't even cancel people who engage
in looting they're trying to bail them
out in the middle of the riots and illa
had Omar will not be canceled for
suggesting we have to rip down the
entire economic and political system of
the United States and the representative
from Minnesota who was taken in by the
most glorious nation in human history
the United States after living a
childhood in war-torn Somalia has come
to the United States and decided that
the entire US system must be taken down
hey she's an American citizen she's
entitled to her opinion this is also a
horrific ly I would say terrible and
particularly ungrateful position to take
about a country it took in you and your
family from one of the worst hell holes
on earth and Somalia there is no way to
define it as a non hellhole it is a
hellhole okay like that that is just
what is it is a war-torn hellhole it has
been for decades and she comes here and
is taken in and she's an American
citizen just as American as you or I but
her position on Americans that America
sucks it needs to be torn down all of
the pillars have to be torn out as long
as our economy and political systems
prioritize profit without considering
who is profiting who is being shut out
we will perpetuate this inequality so we
cannot stop at criminal justice system
we must begin the work of dismantling
the whole system of oppression wherever
we find it okay so she won't be canceled
obviously because too much had left
agrees with this basic premise other
people who will not be cancelled include
why were Eagles wide receiver DeSean
Jackson reposted a quote saying that
white Jews will blackmail and extort
America and quoted Louis Farrakhan and
then apparently quoted Hitler right
featured Nancy's met a quote on his
social media feed he attributed it Adolf
Hitler DeSean Jackson um and people are
like well we have to inform him and
tried him the Eagles put out some
ridiculous statements suggesting we've
had a talk with DeSean Jackson let's put
it this way it's a challenge Jackson
were white and quote and Hitler how long
do you think he'd be in the NFL like
gone right but if you're on the if
you're on the proper woke side of the
aisle like ice cube you can be as Anne
siese Americans you want to be the last
hatred that is allowed in the United
States is hatred of Jews obviously in
sort of the traditional Canon of hatred
of groups you can you as long as you're
on the right side you'll never be
canceled so
the way that this works it meanwhile I
want to make a quick note here about
covet 19 deaths so coca 19 deaths spiked
yesterday in terms of the numbers that
we saw it's hard to tell what that
spiked from yesterday is really
attributable to a big spike that has
happened in deaths or anything was
something like 900 and some deaths
yesterday from COBIT or whether that is
just reporting after the long weekend
meaning that that was reporting from
Tuesday and there was a three-day
weekend so a lot of people didn't go
into the hospital some of those deaths
didn't get reported and so they're
usually this usually happens right the
Monday count is usually pretty low
because you're getting reporting from
Sunday and then the Tuesday count is a
little bit higher and then the Wednesday
count is typically higher than that so
we'll keep an eye on on that obviously
as I've been saying we should continue
to be careful but I'm still cautiously
optimistic the death rates have declined
pretty significantly and we will keep
you informed should any of that change
in in radical fashion okay we'll be back
here tomorrow for much more content so
stick around for that
in the meantime head on over to daily
wire.com subscribe and leave us a review
over in iTunes we always appreciate it
i'm ben shapiro you're listening to the
ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas executive producer Jeremy
boring supervising producer
Mathis Glover and Robert Stirling
assistant director Pavel Whitehouse key
technical producer austin stevens
playback and media operated by Nick
Sheehan associate producer Katy Swinton
edited by Adam SCI events audio is mixed
by micro Romina hair and makeup is by
Anika Geneva the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over at the Andrew
Klavan show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew cliff
[Music]